Verano de 2022.
Todo el Donbass está ocupado por los rusos.
¿Todo?
¡No!
Diversas zonas defendidas por irreductibles
galos, ¡digo, ucranianos!, resisten todavía
y como siempre al invasor.
Por desgracia para Ucrania la clave de su
resistencia no es ninguna poción mágica
sino el apoyo de Occidente.
Y aunque las cosas se desarrollan de una manera
muy diferente a la planificada por el Kremlin,
Rusia logró hacerse con un 20% del territorio
de Ucrania en los primeros 100 días transcurridos
desde que diera comienzo la guerra.
Sí, fracasaron en tomar Kiev y cada metro
de avance le está saliendo muy caro al Ejército
ruso.
Pero también a Ucrania que está perdiendo
una gran cantidad de hombres y está viendo
destruidas muchas infraestructuras críticas
por los ataques rusos.
Pero en esta ocasión nos alejaremos un poco
del frente, al menos de lo que todos identificamos
como tal.
Porque lo que queremos con este vídeo es
echar un vistazo al papel que está jugando
en la guerra lo anunciado por el presidente
de Ucrania el 24 de febrero.
El mismo día que dio comienzo la invasión,
Zelensky dijo esto:
Queridos amigos, amigas, estas unidades de
Defensa Territorial son un componente de la
reserva militar de las Fuerzas Armadas de
Ucrania.
Están movilizadas desde finales de febrero
y en los últimos años han mejorado notablemente
sus capacidades.
Así que la pregunta es:
¿En qué momento surgen las Fuerzas de Defensa
Territorial?
¿Cómo se organizan y cuál es su modus operandi?
Y lo que es más importante: ¿Qué papel
están desempeñando en el actual conflicto
con Rusia?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas.
Pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(LA ROSA Y LA ESPADA)
La desintegración de la Unión Soviética
generó una gran incertidumbre.
Además de Rusia, otras tres antiguas repúblicas
soviéticas se habían quedado en su territorio
con armas nucleares.
Era el caso de Bielorrusia, de Kazajistán
y, por supuesto, de Ucrania, donde quedó
a disposición del nuevo gobierno de Kiev
ni más ni menos que el tercer arsenal nuclear
más grande del mundo.
Por aquel entonces nos encontrábamos al final
de la Guerra Fría.
Como os podréis imaginar, después de pasar
décadas al borde del cataclismo nuclear,
eso de que otros 3 países se unieran al club
del armamento atómico no parecía la mejor
idea.
Así que tal y como decimos en VisualPolitik,
dicho y hecho.
En 1994 Estados Unidos, Reino Unido y Rusia
firmaron con estas antiguas repúblicas soviéticas
el Memorándum de Budapest.
Este acuerdo supuso que estos países entregaran
su arsenal nuclear a Rusia a cambio de recibir
garantías de seguridad por parte de Estados
Unidos, Gran Bretaña e ironías de la vida,
la propia Rusia.
Y claro, aquello no fue el mejor estímulo
para que Ucrania invirtiera en Defensa y modernizara
su Ejército.
(Como tantas otras cosas de la era soviética,
el servicio militar obligatorio es una reliquia
de la que la Ucrania independiente lleva décadas
tratando de deshacerse.
Los tres años de servicio militar en tiempos
de la URSS se han reducido a un período de
entre 12 y 18 meses.
Y aunque la mili fue abolida en 2013 tuvo
que restablecida al año siguiente después
de que Rusia comenzara a apoderarse de territorio
ucraniano.)
Para entonces el pueblo de Ucrania se había
levantado ya dos veces contra el títere de
Putin, el presidente Viktor Yanukovich.
Una en la revolución naranja, por amañar
las elecciones.
Y otra, el Euromaidán, por romper un acuerdo
de asociación con la Unión Europea.
Fue el momento en el que aprendieron por primera
vez que llevar la contraria a Putin no sale
gratis.
Los ucranianos se llevaron un buen golpe de
realidad.
La anexión de Crimea y el comienzo de las
hostilidades en el Donbass por parte de las
guerrillas prorrusas dejaron en evidencia
a sus autoridades.
Que Ucrania sólo tuviera 6.000 soldados preparados
para el combate fue el resultado de décadas
de corrupción.
Un desastre que han tratado de solventar en
los últimos años.
Como podéis ver, Ucrania ha invertido mucho
en modernizar su ejército desde la invasión
de Crimea.
Parece que les ha quedado claro que el memorándum
de Budapest tiene ya menos valor que el Pacto
de Varsovia.
Pero en 2014, el problema de Ucrania era evidente:
el ejército regular era insuficiente y contaba
con un presupuesto que apenas rondaba el 2%
del PIB de uno de los países más pobres
de toda Europa.
Lo que supone que en 2014 el gasto militar
apenas superaba los 2.500 millones de dólares.
Una cantidad claramente insuficiente para
el que es el país más grande de todo el
viejo continente.
Ante semejante panorama, Ucrania confió su
suerte a organizaciones de voluntarios que
estaban dispuestos a defender a su patria.
(La guerra del Donbass causó un gran quebradero
de cabeza en Kiev.
Ante la táctica rusa de apoyar a las guerrillas
de Donetsk y Luhansk así como a diferentes
grupos insurgentes, Ucrania apostó por una
fuerza a medio camino entre lo civil y lo
militar.
Querían que fuera capaz de organizar una
guerrilla en la retaguardia rusa que incomodara
a los invasores.
Y que en el terreno propio fuera útil como
complemento del Ejército.
Ese fue el momento de los conocidos como batallones
de defensa territorial.)
Como bien sabéis, el conflicto del Donbass
se extendió hasta nuestros días.
Así que una preocupación que enseguida surgió
en el Gobierno de Ucrania fue cómo absorber
a estos batallones de defensa territorial
dentro de la propia estructura del Estado.
Durante años se produjo un debate político
eterno sobre cuáles serían sus competencias
y cometidos.
Pero la idea siempre ha sido que sean un complemento
al Ejército.
Sin pretender nunca reemplazar su papel.
El caso es que tanto se alargó el asunto
que no fue hasta el pasado 1 de enero cuando
entró en vigor la Ley de Fundamentos de la
Resistencia Nacional.
Es entonces cuando todos estos batallones
quedaron incorporados en un nuevo cuerpo:
las Fuerzas de Defensa Territorial.
Un nuevo cuerpo que nació apenas 50 días
antes del comienzo de la invasión rusa.
(Las Fuerzas de Defensa Territorial están
constituidas por 25 brigadas, cada una al
servicio del mando militar de cada oblast,
esto es de cada región de Ucrania.
En todo caso, todas ellas son en última instancia
coordinadas por su Cuartel General ubicado
en Kiev.
La ley estipula que cada brigada debía alistar
unos 3.500 hombres divididos en batallones
de 600.
Esto supone que las Fuerzas de Defensa Territorial
contarían con alrededor de 90.000 efectivos.)
Apenas 20 días después de que la Ley entrara
en vigor, el entonces máximo responsable
de las Fuerzas aseguraba que ya estaban preparados.
De esta forma, mientras Rusia no paraba de
acumular fuerzas en la frontera con Ucrania,
el mensaje que enviaba Kiev es que estaban
preparados.
Que las cosas habían cambiado y que en esta
ocasión nos les iban a pillar por sorpresa,
que fue exactamente lo que ocurrió en el
año 2014.
(Yuriy Halushkin, Comandante de las Fuerzas
de Defensa Territorial.
La demanda de armas de fuego y municiones
de las Fuerzas de Defensa Territorial está
totalmente cubierta.)
Al constituirse brigadas en los territorios
que ya estaban en conflicto como Donetsk y
Luhansk, está claro que Kiev ya estaba pensando
en que estas Fuerzas deberían actuar como
una especie de guerrilla o movimiento de resistencia
si finalmente los rusos se adentraban en Ucrania.
Algo así como una fuerza partisana para mantener
viva la llama.
Un cuerpo para controlar la seguridad del
territorio, brindarle apoyo logístico a las
tropas, inteligencia, realizar emboscadas
y operaciones de sabotaje o construir y reparar
infraestructuras militares.
La idea es que la defensa sea mucho más densa
y, por tanto, que el invasor tenga mucho más
difícil controlar el territorio.
El caso es que como todos sabéis, la invasión
finalmente se produjo.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿Qué ha hecho esta
Fuerza de Defensa Territorial desde entonces?
¿Qué papel está jugando en la guerra de
Ucrania?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2(LA GRAN ZANJA)
El 24 de febrero comenzó la invasión de
Ucrania.
El avance ruso inicial fue demoledor.
Avanzando desde Bielorrusia intentaron envolver
Kiev.
En el este llegaron hasta las inmediaciones
de Kharkiv y reafirmaron su dominio sobre
Donetsk y Luhansk.
En el sur avanzaron desde Crimea y tomaron
Melitopol y Kherson antes de comenzar el brutal
asedio de Mariupol.
Llegados a este punto, los ucranianos de las
zonas ocupadas tuvieron que poner en práctica
lo aprendido durante los últimos años.
(Nuestra gente está haciendo todo lo posible
para asegurarse de que la tierra arda bajo
los pies de los ocupantes.
Ivan Fedorov, alcalde de Melitópol.)
Desde que diera comienzo la invasión muchos
ucranianos se han sumado a las Fuerzas de
Defensa Territorial.
Las cifras oficiales indican que en marzo
ya eran unos 100.000.
La verdad es que Ucrania no está teniendo
problemas de efectivos.
Pero ahora bien, hay que diferenciar en estas
fuerzas dos tipos de soldados muy distintos:
por un lado el voluntario civil, que con suerte
antes de la invasión dedicó algún fin de
semana a su adiestramiento pero que evidentemente
carece de conocimientos militares.
Y luego están los profesionales de las fuerzas
armadas y otros cuerpos de seguridad, que
son los que ocupan el rol de oficiales dentro
de este cuerpo.
De hecho muchos veteranos de la guerra del
Donbass optaron por entrar en estas Fuerzas,
tan necesitada de unidades experimentadas
para instruir y guiar a los nuevos voluntarios.
El problema hoy día es que muchos de estos
soldados han optado por ir al frente, donde
están mucho mejor pagados y dónde pueden
tener una contribución mayor en la defensa
nacional.
En cualquier caso, una de las principales
ventajas de los voluntarios civiles es su
conocimiento del terreno.
Jugar en casa les proporciona ventaja para
identificar cuáles son los lugares claves
a defender, organizar emboscadas o detectar
rápidamente a los infiltrados rusos.
Gracias a ellos se han producido la mayor
parte de los arrestos a grupos de sabotaje
que trabajan para el Kremlin en Ucrania.
Y por supuesto, estos voluntarios han sido
armados desde el primer día, desde que el
presidente Zelensky declaró la ley marcial.
(“Armas para todos”: se forman milicias
a lo largo de Ucrania mientras las fuerzas
rusas se acercan)
Amigos, amigas, el objetivo fundamental de
las Fuerzas de Defensa Territorial es llevar
a cabo tareas básicas lejos del frente pero
que requieren un alto número de efectivos.
Hablamos por ejemplo de levantar puestos de
control en las carreteras principales, cavar
zanjas y trincheras, hacer labores de vigilancia
y seguimiento, fortificar posiciones y barricadas…
actividades de las que se pretende liberar
al personal del Ejército propiamente dicho
para que estos puedan centrarse completamente
en las misiones de combate.
(Otra función asignada a las Fuerzas de Defensa
Territorial es participar activamente en la
búsqueda y detección del enemigo en retirada.
Por ejemplo, son capaces de realizar con bastante
eficiencia las llamadas operaciones de limpieza,
lo que incluye el rastreo y captura de pilotos
rusos de aviones y helicópteros derribados.
El objetivo está claro: no dejar ni un enemigo
atrás para proteger la retaguardia del Ejército
ucraniano.)
Por supuesto, en los territorios ocupados
su labor es más peligrosa.
Se necesita tanto valor para sus actividades
como el que los soldados de Ucrania están
mostrando en el frente.
Aún así, las noticias que llegan desde estas
zonas son constantes: desde ataques a una
base aérea controlada por Rusia hasta la
destrucción de un tren blindado e instalaciones
ferroviarias en Melitopol.
Todo sirve para luchar contra el invasor ruso.
Y cuando decimos todo, es todo.
Fijaos.
(Civiles ucranianos matan a soldados rusos
con pasteles envenenados)
En España decimos que lo que no mata, engorda.
En Ucrania no.
Lo que está claro es que la vida ha cambiado
mucho en el país para los que antes del 24
de febrero eran maestros, ingenieros, obreros…
Y también para las empresas.
De la noche a la mañana se han reconvertido
en parte de una economía de guerra que está
trabajando día tras día con un único objetivo:
expulsar a los rusos.
Y al igual que el pueblo de Ucrania se ha
puesto al servicio de la patria con sus Fuerzas
de Defensa Territorial, hay empresas que están
haciendo exactamente lo mismo:
(El mes pasado hacían alta costura.
Ahora están haciendo botas de combate.)
El éxito de Ucrania en la defensa de Kiev
hizo que los rusos pasaran a centrarse en
su ofensiva en el este y sur del país.
Alejar al enemigo de la capital ha hecho posible
que miles de efectivos de las Fuerzas de Defensa
Territorial queden ahora a disposición de
los mandos militares para actuar más cerca
del frente.
Claro que hay dudas acerca de si esto es o
no lo más conveniente.
Atentos.
T3(EL COMBATE DE LOS JEFES)
Zelensky siempre ha sido partidario de que
Ucrania tenga un Ejército más profesional.
Tres semanas antes de que diera comienzo la
guerra, el presidente ucraniano firmó un
decreto en el que apostaba claramente por
aumentar el presupuesto de Defensa y subir
los salarios de sus fuerzas armadas.
Del mismo modo, se fijó para 2024 el final
del servicio militar obligatorio.
Pero claro, la invasión rusa lo ha cambiado
todo.
Y parece que también la opinión del propio
Zelensky.
Esto ha provocado que a mediados de mayo se
produjera una noticia sorprendente que no
ha tenido ninguna explicación oficial.
(Zelensky despide al jefe de las Fuerzas de
Defensa Territorial de Ucrania)
¿Por qué fue despedido Yuriy Halushkin cuando
tan solo habían transcurrido 80 días de
guerra?
¿No estaba acaso haciendo un buen trabajo?
A la vista de cómo se ha defendido Ucrania
está claro que ese no puede ser el motivo.
A ver, sin duda el mérito de repeler a los
rusos debe atribuirse al valor de los soldados
de Ucrania.
Pero también se ha hecho un buen trabajo
en la segunda línea.
Entonces, ¿a qué vino esta destitución?
En su momento hubo rumores de que Halushkin
podría tener ciertas aspiraciones de entrar
en política.
¿Explica acaso esto que Zelensky quisiera
fulminarle antes de que ganara popularidad
y pudiera convertirse en un rival político?
La verdad es que cuesta pensar que el presidente
ucraniano tenga tiempo para este tipo de cálculos.
Con echar a los rusos bastante tiene.
Por eso la clave de esta destitución quizás
tenga más que ver con una noticia que se
produjo apenas dos semanas antes del cese
de Halushkin.
Mirad lo que aprobó el Parlamento de Ucrania
a comienzos de mayo.
(La Rada permite que Defensa Territorial lleve
a cabo tareas en áreas de guerra)
De esta forma la Rada modificó la Ley de
Fundamentos de la Resistencia Nacional 4 meses
después de entrar en vigor.
El principal cambio es que las Fuerzas de
Defensa Territorial operarán en todo el territorio
de Ucrania, incluidas las áreas de operaciones
militares y de combate.
Otro detalle también es muy significativo.
La decisión de ir a estas zonas no la tomará
el Comandante de las Fuerzas de Defensa Territorial
sino el Comandante en Jefe de las Fuerzas
Armadas de Ucrania.
Y mucho ojo al modo en que se ha aprobado
esta reforma legislativa.
(Según el artículo 94 de la Constitución
de Ucrania, el jefe del Estado debe firmar
una ley que se le envíe en un plazo de 15
días o devolverla al parlamento con propuestas
razonables y motivadas.
Si el Presidente no firma la ley en dicho
período y no la envía al parlamento, entonces
la ley entra en vigor.
Es lo que sucedió con esta reforma ya que
Zelensky no la firmó ni la devolvió en el
plazo pertinente tras ser aprobada por la
Rada.)
¿Por qué no siguió Zelensky el procedimiento
habitual previsto por la Constitución?
Posiblemente estamos ante una señal de que
se ha impuesto el deseo de los mandos militares
de ganar más efectivos para combatir a los
rusos en el frente.
Quizás el presidente no quisiera firmar la
ley, haciendo que la responsabilidad de equiparar
a los voluntarios civiles con los soldados
profesionales recaiga sobre los parlamentarios
de la Rada que aprobaron esta ley.
Ahora bien, todo indica que el comandante
de las Fuerzas de Defensa Territorial se opuso
con firmeza a la decisión de enviar a luchar
a sus miembros.
Tanto que a Zelensky no le quedó otra que
destituirlo.
La cuestión es que Halushkin no es el único
que piensa que las Fuerzas de Defensa Territorial
no están preparadas para luchar en primera
línea.
Mac William Bishop, con pasado militar y periodista
freelance que colabora con prestigiosos medios
internacionales, está sobre el terreno y
opina exactamente lo mismo.
(Ucrania ha enviado a toda prisa a todas las
unidades disponibles a la lucha en el este,
incluidas varias brigadas y unidades de voluntarios
mal entrenadas de las Fuerzas de Defensa Territorial.)
(Pasé un tiempo con una de las unidades de
voluntarios que fueron trasladadas al frente
y fue una experiencia alarmante.
Sin ser su culpa, estaban siendo enviados
a la batalla con un equipo mínimo y sin un
entrenamiento básico adecuado.)
El análisis de Bishop asegura que estas unidades
siguen sin estar preparadas para el campo
de batalla.
No tienen ni idea de las tácticas más básicas
de la infantería, lo que les convierte en
blanco fácil para los rusos.
Está claro que los ucranianos están dispuestos
a darlo todo por su patria.
También la vida.
Pero como comprenderéis tampoco se trata
de hacer sacrificios en vano.
Para poder cumplir su misión: los ucranianos
necesitan dos cosas: armas modernas y entrenamiento.
Para lo primero cuentan con la ayuda de Occidente.
El entrenamiento es más complicado.
Necesitan tiempo y en la guerra este es un
bien escaso.
Sea como sea si algo está claro es que esta
Fuerza de Defensa Territorial está jugando
un papel muy relevante en Ucrania.
Tanto que países como Polonia ya han empezado
a copiar esta estructura.
Pero dicho esto turno para ti, ¿Estás de
acuerdo con utilizar todos los efectivos disponibles
para combatir al invasor ruso?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo no olvides darle a like y compartirlo
con tus amigos.
No olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.